The new "Dungeons & Dragons" movie is drawing
comparisons to an entirely different and very
popular franchise. But is that a good thing
or a bad thing? Here's what fans are saying.
Paramount Pictures has debuted a new trailer for
their upcoming fantasy epic "Dungeons & Dragons:
Honor Among Thieves," causing fans to
draw flattering comparisons to one of
the most beloved movies of the 2010s. The film,
which is adapted from the vast lore of the
tabletop role-playing game of the same name,
boasts a stacked cast including Chris Pine,
Michelle Rodriguez, and Regé-Jean Page.
Despite this impressive roster, the
project faces an uphill battle. Though
the "Dungeons & Dragons" brand is as popular
as it's ever been thanks to its inclusion in
shows like "Stranger Things," making a film or
television series as engaging and satisfying
as an interactive game is a challenge. Plus,
past adaptations haven't quite hit the mark.
Regardless, some fans have noted that
it shares many positive traits with a
beloved film from the Marvel Cinematic
universe, "Guardians of the Galaxy."
In the comments of the latest "Dungeons &
Dragons: Honor Among Thieves'" trailer on
YouTube, one person aptly subtitled the film,
"Guardians of the Galaxy: Fantasy Edition."
From the vibrant color palette to the
remixed Led Zeppelin backing track,
the trailer really is packed with
"Guardians" vibes. This could work
in "Honor Among Thieves'" favor if it is
able to capture the magic of that film.
"Guardians of the Galaxy" was a runaway
hit that turned some of comics' most
obscure characters into household
names overnight. Because it couldn't
rely exclusively on name recognition,
"Guardians of the Galaxy's" success
was due largely to the sharp humor
and vibrant direction of James Gunn.
"Hey! If it isn't Star Prince."
"Starlord."
"Oh, sorry, Lord."
Now, the tone Gunn found in "Guardians
of the Galaxy" is being felt in "Honor
Among Thieves" with its brilliant blend
of humor with excellent characterizations.
To many fans, this is a great sign that
the creative team understands the spirit
of "Dungeons & Dragons." It's supposed to be
silly and feel like you and your buddies got
together to play a game and joke around for
a little bit. As one person said on Twitter:
"So the new D&D movie is basically 'Guardians
of the Galaxy' with a dungeon crawl. I
think that's something we can work with."
"Sounds lovely."
"Quite the opposite."
On the r/movies subreddit, where
redditors gathered to discuss the
new trailer for "Dungeons & Dragons:
Honor Among Thieves," one user wrote,
"People have been saying for 8 years
that 'Guardians of the Galaxy' felt
like a tabletop RPG adventure being
played by actual players. I wouldn't
be surprised if the pitch for this
movie was just holding up a blu-ray
of that movie and then slapping on a
'Lord of the Rings' sticker or two."
The banter isn't the only aspect of the
trailer that harkens back to Peter Quill
and his crew. A perfect example of this comes in
the trailer's first moments, in which Michelle
Rodriguez's Holga the Barbarian defeats a team
of enemies with her hands bound. Meanwhile,
Chris Pine's Edgin the Bard attempts to
saw his own ropes off on some stairs.
"You know what? I'm thinking there are
probably sharper stairs somewhere else."
This moment not only seems like something
that could occur on the starship Milano,
but it could also happen by dumb luck
in an actual D&D game among friends.
While the characters and their personalities
certainly resemble the "Guardians" crew,
the overall feel of the film is what truly
seems to be getting fans excited for "Honor
Among Thieves." If the film can capture that
familial friendship that can be found in both the
"Guardians" franchise and the most magical games
of "Dungeons & Dragons," it may be a huge success.